everything good things starting out 2023  just as they ended 2022. hey hey hey I'm  sick of you man what I'm sick of you  what happened you interrupted Ernie  already the first show of the year you  already interrupted him can he finish  his monologue  stop  okay  here's what's another YouTube too so I  didn't see the show yeah here's three  years Chuck at it already  bro Mama I'm Coming Home  you want to talk about the Joker go  ahead go ahead no no no it's just no  because every time I want to talk you  want to interrupt me will you allow him  to talk about the Jokers you know how  much your mom means to me right and I  just want to say man between the Papa  John's and the general man putting on  commercials is really awesome very good  she loves you too yeah she's awesome she  loves you I don't be nice if you put me  in okay trust me I know I just like  Shannon I know what it's like to work  with somebody you hate